Helpsters, our goal is to help Beatrice Builder build a sand
castle.
I like this board.
[KNOCKS]
It's sturdy.
Yeah.
I'm glad you approve.
Now who's got an idea, huh?
We do!
Oh!
Mr. Primm and Scatter, go!
First we need something-- --to help us build the sand castle
And we believe that something should be
Sandwiches!
Tools!
Oh.
Yours is better.
Tools, tools, tools.
OK, yeah.
That would be great.
Yeah, it would be great.
So that's job one.
[BELL DINGS] Get tools to build a sand castle.
All right, anything else?
We need sand.
Job two--
[BELL DINGS] --get sand.
All right!
And so, if we have tools and we have sand then job three is?
Build a sand castle!
[BELL DINGS] Yeah!
Beatrice, we have our plan.
(SINGING) We've got the plan, got the plan.
We figured it out.
We've got the plan.
What happens when we've got the plan?
We give a happy shout just cause we can.
Woo!
Cody!
Beatrice!
Scatter and I have tools for the sand castle.
Oh!
Follow me, follow me.
Keep following, keep following, keep following, and-- followed!
Scatter, the tools we have assembled.
Oh!
They're all in this bucket.
Yes.
Great.
There's a ruler.
Mmm-hmm, yes.
There's a wrench, and a pencil.
Mmm, yes.
That's a tool you use to draw.
How can those tools help Beatrice build the sandcastle,
huh?
Oh!
Goodness, Cody is right!
These tools don't help at all!
Nuh-uh.
We need to think of something that will help
shape the sand into a castle.
Hmm.
Wait a minute.
Bucket.
Bucket of sand.
Sandcastle.
Bucket--
What is happening?
He's getting an idea.
We can fill the bucket with sand,
then flip the bucket over.
That is a great idea, Mr. Primm!
But can I get another bucket that looks a little different?
Oh yeah, because that way parts of the castle
can look a little different.
Exactly!
OK, so how about the rule is if a bucket is
a different shape than this bucket, then
that is a bucket we want, huh?
Yeah.
OK.
Got one!
This appears to be the same shape.
Then that's not a bucket we want!
Nuh-uh.
Oh, here's one.
Oh, it's a different shape.
Then that's a bucket we want.
Get tools to make a sandcastle?
[BELL DINGS]
Check!
One job done, two more to go.
Yeah!
Cody!
Beatrice!
Good news.
Come with me!
Come on!
So, uh, where is the sandbox?
Right here.
Oh.
OK, I see what happened here.
Yeah, Heart, we need a box with enough sand
to build a sand castle.
You know like something like a sandbox
you see on a playground with lots of sand.
Oh!
Wait here.
Huh?
[HEART CHUCKLES] [SAWING AND HAMMERING SOUNDS]
Whoa!
Ta-da!
Do you like it?
It's perfect!
Mmm-hmm!
Get sand?
[BELL DINGS]
Check!
One sand castle coming up!
All right!
Fill the bucket with sand--
Yeah, yeah, yeah
--and, ta-daaa!
Oh.
It's another lump.
No.
Aw, the sand isn't sticking together.
I'll never be able to build anything with sand.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Don't you give up Beatrice.
Maybe relax.
Have a drink of water.
Oh, I have water.
Ope!
Oh, sorry, Beatrice, I got your sand all wet.
Yes, but look!
Now that it's wet, it's sticking together.
I bet that'll work with the bucket.
Beatrice, try making a sandcastle now.
Fill the bucket, pat it down real good, and ta-daa!
Now that's something, yeah?
Yea!
Yes sir!
OK, fill the bucket with sand, pat it down real good again--
Uh-huh.
--and Ta-da!
Yea!
That looks so great!
OK, OK, one more.
OK.
Ta-da!
Wow.
That is so, so, so cool.
OK, let me just make a few final touches.
And-- done.
[TRIUMPHANT MUSIC] Wow.
Whoa.
Now that is a castle made of sand.
Wait, one last thing.
Build a sand castle?
[BELL DINGS] Check!
All the jobs are done.